[Applause]
hello hello i'm so happy to be here
i'm the honored one because i'm a huge
fan of you ever since you're being a
baby
i am so excited that you are here for so
many reasons i didn't know how much you
are trained in like
kafka and dostoyevsky and mammoth
all of this heavy drama and then you
come on to the scene and you steal our
hearts
but more incredible you
break through and get nominated for a
comedic performance
at the academy awards which is just
notoriously
impossible you did it i'm so
impressed i'm so happy for you
tutor i wish i could say it just like
borat i love your relationship with
sasha baron cohen who's also nominated
for the trial of chicago 7. you guys
have this
wonderful chemistry together what was
that like
working with him it's been extremely
inspiring because
sasha is a superhero he's extremely
smart
it's kind of scary how smart he is
because he has a feeling that his brain
never stopped working it's like click
click click click click like clock
uh and there is always potentially a
better idea a better joke
so the script was ever evolving with the
greatest team that you can imagine and
we had three women writing to this
uh to this storyline and
um he's a genius he is a genius
it's insane but there is an insane
amount of intelligence to what he has
brought to the world starting from ali g
and into borat into many of the
characters he's played
and this film is
boy does it have a lot of commentary on
the world we live in
i have to ask you about the scene with
rudy giuliani holy cow
what was that moment like and could it
have gone farther if sasha hadn't
stepped in
i was hoping that maybe scene will go in
a different direction because
the more i think about the more i
realized that for me as maria
is about how men sometimes most
times unfortunately treat women and that
this equality that we're fighting for
and i hope my generation will start
demanding
is unfortunately not there yet and but
we have to work for it
uh to create it because women
a lot of times have been seen as sexual
objects
and that's not really the right thing to
be done
because i'm thinking about um maybe
he would have behaved differently if i
was a man journalist
i was relieved when sasha stepped in
because i'm like even though he's like
in a teddy
you know and like in this hilarious
outfit it brings like a sigh of relief
because it just seems like it could have
gone the distance it
you guys pushed the envelope so far in
this film
and i'm so happy for you that it is
being recognized
in a way that i think a drama typically
would
it's a serious movie filled with a lot
of commentary
a lot of exploration and examination of
society
and women and men and i i mean
i'm really grateful for what you put out
into the world and i'm grateful for how
it's being received
i do want to see our movie it is a riot
against misogyny and against subjugating
women but
at the same time not with like this is
so bad this is so wrong
just it's gonna guide you to the way
that you will be okay so maybe next time
i'm gonna think before do something um
because it does revealing people's true
colors and
we all need to to do that i think i hope
well i completely completely agree
now speaking of men of comedy who
never lack heart you're working with
judd apatow right now
yes can you tell me anything about this
movie i'm such a judd apatow fan
i'm freaking out i love him so much i'm
too
and um so the movie is going to follow
the story of
actors that are going to try to finish a
movie during the pandemic
it's not going to feel like a pandemic
movie and something that is gonna feel
us
make us feel bad it's gonna feel more
like a holiday movie because it's
a lot of people um that are gonna
make you feel harm-warmed heart-warmed
yeah he he never lacks heart that's why
i love him
i'm so excited to see the judd apatow
movie and everything that you do
and um make sure to check out borat
subsequent movie film if you haven't
already because
everybody has it's on amazon prime and
good luck on sunday we'll be cheering
you on